You know that Sunday night dread? You're
not anxious. You're not broken. You're
playing the wrong game. Most of us are
NPCs in someone else's game. Following
scripts we never wrote. Chasing goals we
never chose. Living the dream. Yeah.
Whose dream exactly? Here's what nobody
tells you. You're using the wrong
scoreboard. Salary, followers, status.
These metrics, they're measuring someone
else's game, not yours. The plot twist.
Your authentic game already exists. You
don't have to create it. You have to
uncover it. Pay attention to what you do
when you procrastinate. Those rabbit
holes, those midnight conversations,
that's you escaping to your game. The
ultimate truth. When you stop trying to
win their game, you start succeeding at
yours.